so you don't know this like you don't
know any of the background of this
Ashgar but surely Abdo is a secularist
far left-wing anti-racist magazine it
has made a particular delight in recent
years quite rightly of lampooning and
attacking very violently the far-right
wing leader marine lepen you say rubbish
because you don't know what you're
talking maybe the more award you smell
this little may have a more debate are
we going to talk that yeah it made hair
the important point on this which is
that this is not to do with the war on
terror that scar Bukhari once that's
what I did was speak but more let you
know importantly you have been massively
diverted in this program from what has
actually happened and why what is going
on at the moment worldwide and
particularly in Europe is an attempt to
shut down any and all criticism of Islam
one religion alone I'll hold up for a
moment don't worry it's not a cartoon of
Mohammed you don't have to get scared
this is a Christmas edition of Private
Eye an issue and image which on the
front cover Lampoon's are quite rightly
quite amusing not very the Virgin Mary
and Jesus and has various jokes about
about where the frankincense should have
been bought from and so on that's
perfectly commonplace but you know what
if any one had gone into privatized
offices yesterday and massacred the
staff because of it in the name of
Christianity or Jesus I think that not
only would all of the papers today have
been a block more robust they would have
shown at the very least shown this image
to show what the person was who kid that
did the killing was so irate about the
fact is that there is something going on
which we have to identify it is an
attack and attempt in our societies to
make Islam and in particular the founder
Islam immune from any criticism it
cannot be allowed to continue